arriving in Taiwan on a private trip at
least that's the official explanation a
delegation from the United States a
former deputy secretary of state and a
former National Security adviser their
arrival less than 24 hours after the
election of taiwan's new president
doesn't appear to be a coincidence first
on the agenda a meeting with outgoing
president tying Wan she's been a
reliable Ally during her two terms
despite provocation from China we look
forward the continuity in the
relationship between Taiwan and the
United States under the new
Administration and for common efforts to
preserve cross straight peace and
stability and a warm handshake from the
president-elect the relationship with
the US will be vital during his term in
power thank you to the US side for its
long-standing firm and unwavering
support for Taiwan I believe that Taiwan
us relations Under The Joint efforts of
both sides will continue to move
forward tensions have been rising in the
Taiwan Straits in recent years prompting
military exercises on both sides with
major conflicts in Ukraine and the
Middle East ongoing Washington DC
doesn't need any more problems quietly
they're likely to press president-elect
Li to curb his more confrontational
instincts under table I think there is a
main purpose of its visit that is
preventive diplomacy the US would like
to prevent the newly elected William Li
to be more assertive or provactive the
buzzword around here for the last few
days has been continuity maintaining the
status quo that's what taiwan's new
president says he wants and the United
States but it's not yet clear if China
is listening Tony Chang Al jazer
Tai Taiwan has lost one of its remaining
diplom diplomatic allies two days after
it elected a new president the Pacific
island of Naru says it will not
recognize the government in thaay it's
switching ties to China Taiwan accuses
Beijing of pressuring its allies and
China claims Taiwan as its territory a
position Taiwan rejects Brian Hugh is
the founder and editor of new blo
Magazine online publication that focuses
on Taiwan and the Asia Pacific he joins
us now from taip thanks very much for
being with us so first of all what do
you make of this decision uh by the
government in Naru and in particular the
timing of it right after the election of
the of the new president in
Taiwan yeah that's right the timing is a
mere two days after the election and so
it's a sign of how China is registering
displeasure of Taiwan for exercising its
democracy Taiwan has been engaged in
this struggle with China regarding its
diplomatic allies for some time China
often will seek to poach diplomatic
allies of Taiwan if there's a DPP
presidential Administration and with an
incoming presidential Administration
that is also of the DPP China is quick
to register displeasure in this way
expected some flexing mus would occur
and this the way it has chosen to do
so and um how much of a of a I mean what
let's let's talk about Naro first of all
what does this mean um for Naro it's a
small island um but it has a
relationship with Taiwan but obviously
China has a lot more money
absolutely and so Naru has a population
depending on some census counts of up to
10,000 around 10,000 a bit more a bit
less sometimes but it's a very small
country and then particularly if you do
emphasize diplomatic relation with
Taiwan rather than that of China
recognizing the Republic of China the
official name by which Taiwan is known
rather than the People's Republic of
China you're losing out on the Chinese
market and you may fight attempts by
China to pressure you and so it does
make sense as to why Naru has decided to
switch here Taiwan cannot outbid China
in terms terms of its incentives that
offers Naru but the timing of course is
after the election that is suspicious
and how much of a blow is this for
Taiwan then dwindling number um of
Nations small number to begin with of
Nations that recognized
Taiwan it's not a huge loss uh because
it is such a small country and taiwan's
unofficial relations with the US for
example and other Western powers are of
much more importance uh but that's
symbolic value and it shows that China
attempts to intimidate Taiwan will
continue and it also gives the
opposition KT the historically pro-china
party in taiwan's politics the uh
political ammunation that it will use
into Li's new upcoming term and so
claiming that with the DPP
Administration you'll have continuing
shrinking International Space this loss
of diplomatic allies and then framing
this as the dpp's fault rather than that
of Chinese
pressure good to talk to you Brian Hugh
thanks very
much thank you